welcome to game yo what would you like
to preorder today oh no I just wanted to
buy the new Salomon game let me check
uh okay do you want
Salomon polyethylene or polystyrene
what's the difference well if you want
to catch all the phalam on you have to
trade with a friend or if you're sad and
lonely you can buy both I'll go with
polystyrene because the one on the front
looks better everyone does
yes game time
what are we playing today Aleman
polystyrene edition a alright see you in
there got a plasticizer mom hello there
welcome to the world of Taliban people
call me the fella mon professeur this
world is inhabited by salomon they come
from chemicals called phthalates and
they are used to change the properties
of plastics people use phthalates for
all sorts of purposes they can soften
plastic make it more flexible make
plastic more transparent or increase
plastics durability me I study phalam on
your own
Salomon adventure is about to begin
here's to thalam on my assistant polymer
will help you but what will you be doing
don't worry about that go on you heard
him
there's a lot to do hey wait I knew I
should have picked up the guide what are
we even looking for that LeMond they're
used in making plastics and can be found
almost everywhere you can find them
around toys food packaging medical bags
and tubing plastic coatings and even
some products that aren't made of
plastic by an overly expensive vinyl toy
phthalates
like that new car smell phthalates in
the air feel how smooth your hair is
after shampooing phthalates in the
shampoo like the feel of that slick
plastic video game system phthalates
please what let's see what you got
let us tell them on out
I'm so so that's Dyson onal phthalate
it's a pretty common plasticizer
plasticizer sure any chemical that gives
plastics that flexible smooth quality we
like in products is called a plasticizer
oh it's cute too
I wouldn't do that he may cause cancer
the state of California recognizes Dyson
onal as a carcinogen why would the
professor's study phthalates if they're
dangerous
that's exactly why salim on are
everywhere but we aren't sure how much
they affect us some dilates may increase
the risk of getting certain kinds of
cancers and others may be endocrine
disrupters is this one of those
educational games that grandparents
accidentally gifted kids your endocrine
system is a complex group of chemicals
in your body turning on and off chemical
reactions that keep things relatively
normal in you things like your growth
rate blood sugar levels and internal
temperature are all regulated with help
from your endocrine system the
phthalates that our endocrine disruptors
get in your body and block or imitate
endocrine chemicals so how do we find
that Aman aren't they in the plastic
yeah but phthalates don't actually bind
to the plastic plastics are made of an
interlocking web of large molecules
called polymers trapped inside the
polymers are other chemicals like
phthalates phthalates are much smaller
chemicals and they're just mixed in
there so if the plastic is heated cut up
or dissolved the polymers loosen and out
come the phthalates who is that to cover
the world in plastic Sheen to wrap your
stuff and keep it clean to create any
shape your heart's desire to cast old
materials into the fire petrol
truly a sight to behold don't mess with
us we break the mold Nollywood that's
bold
oh gosh not these guys what do you want
we know you've caught rare Taliban they
can help us create more plastics so give
them up or pay the price
what the heck when you lose we're taking
your thalam on you don't get it we have
to study them we can't just keep
cranking out more plastics without
understanding what effects they have on
us ball ring get him go benzyl butyl Ben
go die ethyl okay hey so on ones not
fair he missed a point we had a bad guys
watch out benzyl butyl phthalates is
common in soft plastics it can be found
in Road cones vinyl toys and fake
leather it's illegal to use that Balam
on in Europe what about the gas that's
diethyl phthalate it binds to perfumes
odds are if you smell something nice dye
Ethel's there there are also concerns
about its effects on our nervous system
send out a phalam on right dye coddle I
choose you wow you're really lucky
that's die coddle terephthalate that
thalam on uses plant oils instead of
synthetic chemicals it's a natural
alternative to other phthalates and
research suggests they don't have the
same health concerns oh it's cute show
them dye coddle these kids aren't
playing around show them what we've got
so far late yeah that's a legendary
phalam on its effect is seen in most
plastics polyvinyl chloride or PVC is a
very common plastic if a plastic is PVC
diethyl hexyl was involved it's a cheap
phthalates to use but it also has self
CERN's this one stop it looks like guy
coddle terephthalate may be a powerful
plasticizer but it's also expensive to
use ready to give up twerp way go
diazinon oh it sure isn't this isn't
working either
wait look at the ice and onal the
chemical reaction of hydrogenation
turned Dyson on all into hexa mall and
look at its attacks the harmful side
effects of Dyson oh no are gone adding
hydrogen to this phthalates made it less
reactive this new phthalates could be
better than diethyl hexyl hexam all
seismic malleability what
it's difficult to decide what to do
about phalates the plastics that make
things like medical tubing save millions
of lives on the other hand people who
need constant medical treatment are at
greater risk of the negative side
effects of phthalates
they could stay in the plastic or they
could get out and enter your body
through your blood eating food or just
breathing but with work we can make our
plastics safer if we look for natural
alternatives like die caudal all the
research methods for creating safer
phthalates like hexanol we can have our
plastics and minimize the risk it may
take money and time but it's better than
surrounding ourselves with products that
have unknown effects there's also ways
we can just avoid using plastics shop
with a canvas bag eat off of glass or
ceramic plates and use metal flatware
and keep your plastics away from heat in
microwaves and dishwashers that break
down plastics and if lazy elites and
don't chew on your plastic stuff it's
understandable for a baby but come on so
we beat the bad guys and learned a lot
did I beat the game oh you never beat
this game
there's post game missions you have to
play the other version there's the
tradable card game in about five years
they'll do a remake of this game you're
never done this is you now